In the name of the Father and of the Son and of the Holy Spirit, Amen.
The reading from the Sinaxadion for June 8th, on which we commemorate the venerable
Naukratius, the younger brother of St. Basil the Great.
The younger brother of St. Basil the Great, St. Naukratius, was born in about 330.
Of all the brothers, Naukratius was the most richly endowed.
With his happy, natural disposition, his beauty, his strength and agility, and his competence
in every domain.
At the age of 22, he showed such talent as an orator during a public debate, that he
amazed the assembly.
Yet, inspired by the love of God, he renounced a worldly career to take up the solitary life
together with a servant named Christophus, in a place not far from the river Iris in Pontus,
covered with a dense forest and hidden in the cleft of a rock.
Taking nothing with him, he lived concentrated in himself and detached from the troubles
of the city and the preoccupations of the world.
Obedient and submissive to his mother, who lived with St. Macrina in their house, which they
had transformed into a monastery, a three-day journey on foot from his hermitage.
He put himself at the service of some elderly, sick and indigent men, who provided them with
food by his ability in hunting and fishing.
He had lived this life in conformity with true philosophy for five years, when he was killed
in hunting accident, along with his faithful companion, Christophus.
This event was a great affliction to his mother, but thanks to her spiritual strength and the
greatness of St. Macrina's soul, she overcame her sorrow, and rather than continue to grieve
at the thought of his absence, she rejoiced at the lot reserved for her son in heaven.
Through the prayers of our Holy Fathers, O Lord Jesus Christ our God, of mercy on us and
save us.